un voleur d'être communauté l'extrême
2016 un individu non identifié a volé
leur mascotte alors vous envoyer une
brigade sur les lieux et vous fait
intervenir la police scientifique pour
des prélèvements adn pour jean-claude
procédure habituelle
tu commences par l'extérieur et puis tu
prélève tout ce que tu peux ok
aujourd'hui mon collègue et moi même
nous intervenons sur une scène
d'infraction
nous sommes de la pts la police
technique et scientifique mais une
différence nous sépare aujourd'hui jean
claude lui c'est la vraie police
scientifique celle du terrain
premièrement parce qu'il est une
combinaison qui lui permet de ne pas
contaminer la scène et aussi parce qu'il
s'appelle jean claude et jean claude
c'est pas très sexy pour les séries télé
forcément
moi au contraire je suis habillé comme
les experts la télé vous savez ces
experts qui sont jean chemise en tee
shirt
en costume pantalon en eau et qui vont
aller sur la scène de crime sans
protection pardon excusez moi jean
claude est pas content il a raison vous
savez c'est super expert c'est
désespérant tous savent tout faire
yvon sur les scènes de crime et en une
fraction de seconde ils vont trouver
'l'indice clé qui va révolutionner
l'enquète ils vont faire des
prélèvements
il va les envoyer aux laboratoires et
aux laboratoires
ils vont trouver la trace parfaite celle
qui marche à chaque fois et en quelques
secondes avoir l'identité du tube de
l'agresseur et enfin après une course
poursuite entre les voitures
ils vont l'arrêter le mettre en prison
et tout ça grâce à quoi
grâce au fait que l'adn du suspect était
sur la scène de crime
et puis dans les séries bd quai de l'adn
forcément on est coupable mais ce qui
est plus important c'est que tout ça ils
le font en moins de 45 minutes juste
avant le générique de fin
dans les experts étaient les bains ils
sont vraiment trop forts
sauf que bon évidemment tout ça c'est
presque que de la fiction la réalité ce
sont les centaines d'agents spécialisés
de la pts
qui interviennent toute l'année sur des
scènes de petite et moyenne délinquance
à la recherche d'un 10 la réalité ce
sont les centaines de techniciens de
laboratoire qui vont analyser jusqu'à
quarante mille prélèvements par mois
pour trouver des traces pertinente la
réalité ce sont les centaines de
policiers scientifiques qui sont
intervenus de jour comme de nuit lors
des attentats à paris en 2015 la réalité
c'est aussi jean claude et finalement la
réalité c'est un petit peu moi aussi
parce que depuis deux ans je suis
ingénieur de police technique et
scientifique
aliens vs l'institut national de police
scientifique qui est basé à lyon voir
lyon c'est pas si exotique ça par
rapport à miami new york ou las vegas
mais pour tous les policiers
scientifiques du monde c'est une ville
qui est très importante parce que c'est
la première ville au monde dans laquelle
un laboratoire 2 pts a été créé et ça
c'était il ya plus de 100 ans
il ya plus de 100 ans en fait on
travaillait pas encore sur ma discipline
de prédilection la génétique
alors pour être honnête je me destinais
pas forcément à devenir policier j'avais
choisi des études relativement classique
en biologie j'ai obtenu un doctorat en
génétique moléculaire et puis je suis
parti en post-doctorat aux états unis
près de boston pour travailler là bas
pour devenir chercheur et puis
finalement c'est ma propre génétique qui
m'a un peu rattrapé
parce que avec un grand père gendarme et
puis un père policier mais bon ils ont
dû me transmettre quelque chose je sais
pas mais en finale mon job
aujourd'hui c'est de faire parler l'adn
dans les enquêtes criminelles
alors l'adn je vous en parle depuis tout
à l'heure mais finalement qu'est ce que
c'est donc adn ja ça veut dire acide
désoxyribonucléique si vous le placez
bien ça vous fait 160 points au scrabble
à peu près il ya des bonnes consonnes et
l'adn en fait c'est le support de
l'information génétique
vous avez l'adn présent dans toutes vos
cellules et il va contenir sous forme
codée des informations qui vous sont
propres qui vous rendent unique
donc en fait au final la dnc comme une
carte d'identité mais génétique
elle est unique
commençons notre enquête yg en vol un
vol qui s'est passé sur la scène du tmx
et à la mascotte teddy qui a été volé
alors lors du vol le gardien a vu un
individu patrouille et un petit peu
autour de la scène mais comme il avait
un badge sur lui il n'a pas forcément
prêté beaucoup d'attention
il a été entendu par les services de
police il a pu donner quelques
informations parcellaires une taille
plutôt moyenne des vêtements sombres une
capuche sur la tête il n'a pas vu son
visage ils pensent qu'il s'agit d'un
homme mais en fait finalement il en est
même pas sûr
et ça c'est dommage parce que si on
avait des informations plus précises
on aurait pu établir un portrait-robot
le portrait robot comme vous le savez
c'est permettent d'établir une
représentation graphique d'un individu à
partir de témoignages de victimes ou de
témoin qui vont donner quelques clés
d'éléments caractéristiques
par exemple est-ce qu'il avait une
moustache et une barbe à ce qu'ils
avaient des yeux clairs des cheveux
foncés
est-ce qu'il avait une cicatrice ou un
signe particulier c'est autant
d'éléments qui vont permettre d'établir
si possible un portrait-robot fiable
pour aider les enquêteurs à orienter
leurs enquêtes
mais dans la réalité finalement c'est
beaucoup plus complexe que ça dans les
séries à chaque fois ça marche
le portrait robot et très concordants
dans la réalité le choc émotionnel par
les victimes ou par les témoins est
énorme
finalement le cerveau n'a que quelques
secondes pour réagir et la plupart du
temps les souvenirs vont être
extrêmement floue alors je vais vous
poser une question est ce que vous avez
une idée du nombre de portraits robots
qui ont été éditées par la police
nationale en france en 2015
la réponse c'est 260
alors je sais pas vous mais moi quand
j'ai commencé dans le métier honnêtement
je m'attendais à plusieurs milliers et
en fait c'est encore un billet 10 séries
télé qui montre qu'à chaque fois ça
marche c'est en réalité c'est beaucoup
beaucoup plus complexe que ça d'ailleurs
une autre question
concernant la fiabilité de ces portraits
robots à votre avis combien de portraits
robots sont conformes à la réalité est
là encore la réponse c'est 12% alors 12
% c'est extrêmement faible on peut
monter ce score jusqu'à 37%
si on utilise les nouvelles méthodes
d'entretien cognitif qui vont permettre
aux victimes de se rappeler un petit peu
plus d'éléments
mais ça c'est toujours extrêmement
faible et le problème c'est que quand
vous avez un portrait robot qui est
discordants la réalité pas ça peut
freiner l'enquète et la perturber est
l'un des exemples clé c'est la sphère
dit georges non guy georges un tueur en
série qui a été condamné pour sept
meurtres et une tentative de meurtre à
l'époque guy georges avait été arrêté
par la police pour interrogation mais
comme il avait aucun trait commun avec
le portrait robot qui avait été établi
quelques mois auparavant
mais il avait été relâché il a pu
continuer ses méfaits et finalement
c'est suite à cette affaire qu'un
fichier national a été créé ce qu'on
appelle le sneg le fichier national
automatisé des empreintes génétiques et
ce fichier va contenir tous les profils
adn des mises en cause ou des condamnés
pour des affaires délictuelle ou
criminelle en france
il va également contenir toutes les
traces adn non identifié qui sont
relevés sur des scènes de crime
voilà des résultats
merci
alors
au cours du vol on va reprendre notre
enquête l'individu a fait tomber un
badge avec un faux nom s'est démarqué
tlx c'est pas sans vraiment ce badge en
fait il est très probablement portée il
a sûrement été en contact avec lui
donc ça peut être aussi dire que le
coupable est peut-être dans cette salle
peut-être juste à côté de vous en faites
et donc ce qui va être fait aux
laboratoires
le badge va être soumis à un prélèvement
adn
donc un prélèvement adn ça se fait comme
ça évidemment dans un laboratoire fermé
bien protégés vous prenez un écouvillon
c'est les cotons tiges des séries et
vous aller frotter sur les zones
particulières vous pensez qu'il ya
peut-être eu un contact vous allez en
extraire l'adn établir un profil
génétique et l'envoyer au fichier
national et voir si ça match voir si une
correspondance entre votre profil
génétique est quelqu'un qui aurait déjà
été rentrée dans la base
on va regarder et non ya pas de match
ça veut dire que l'individu n'a jamais
était rentré dans le fichier son
identité
elle est inconnue donc et une solution
je suis pas sûr vous soyez pour on
pourrait prélever l'adn de chacun
d'entre vous dans cette salle et
comparez vos profils génétiques au
profil génétique trouvée sur le badge
alors forcément ça prendrait beaucoup de
temps
ça coûterait cher la communauté et puis
surtout ça nous ferait tous raté le bus
fait de ce soir donc en réalité en plus
ce type de prélèvement de masse on ne le
fait que pour les affaires extrêmement
grave pour les crimes
donc finalement pour une enquête comme
celle ci les enquêteurs de police s'ils
avaient épuisé toutes les pistes aurait
qu'une seule chose à faire c'est
d'attendre d'attendre qu'un jour la
personne peut-être récidive qu'elle soit
arrêtée qu'on prélève son adn qu'on
fasse à une interrogation au niveau du
fichier et qu'on puisse croiser les
affaires entre elles là le problème
c'est qu'on peut pas
mais ça c'était avant parce que depuis
deux ans en france une nouvelle façon
d'analyser l'adn est autorisée et ça
tombe bien parce que depuis deux ans je
suis responsable de la recherche et du
développement
aliens vs et le but de mon groupe c'est
permettent d'établir des nouvelles
méthodes innovantes pour aider les
enquêteurs
lorsqu'on a des enquêtes complexes et
l'un des projets dont je m'occupe
c'est ce qu'on appelle le portrait-robot
génétique alors le portrait robot
génétique
qu'est ce que c'est
le portrait robot génétique sait prédire
les catégories les caractéristiques
morphologiques d'un individu directement
à partir de son adn qui l'a laissé sur
un support ce principe c'est en fait
qu'on appelle le principe de l' échange
de l'eau car c'est à dire que un
malfaiteur qui va intervenir sur une
scène va laisser des traces de son
passage ça peut être de l'adn ça peut
être une trace ça peut être des filles
de vêtements et il va ensuite partir de
la scène et emporté avec lui des traces
de la scène s'appelle de la terre ça
peut être des résidus de tir par exemple
et cet échange de l'eau qu'un en fait
vous êtes tous en train de le faire et
vous savez peut-être même pas vous êtes
en train de le faire lorsque vous buvez
une bouteille d'eau vous laisse un peu
de salive sur le goulot par exemple
lorsque vous allez vous asseoir sur
votre fauteuil quelques cheveux vont
tomber et moi quand je tiens ce pointeur
par exemple les quelques cellules qui
vont être dessus knoxy on revient au
portrait robot génétique
on va essayer d'orienter lé enquête et
permet de découvrir qui est le coupable
qui peut être potentiellement dans cette
salle
alors si vous le voulez bien je vais
demander votre participation et jeu
devant le mode et je vous demandais de
tous vous lever s'il vous plaît pour
m'aider a attrapé le suspect
donc nous allons utiliser cette nouvelle
méthode le portrait-robot génétique pour
analyser la trace sur le badge et
essayer d'orienter les enquêteurs à un
profil en particulier premièrement nous
allons faire une analyse des chromosomes
donc les chromosomes
il ya des chromosomes sexuels et
lorsqu'on fait des analyses des
chromosomes on voit que c'est un
individu qui a un chromosome x et un
chromosome y
ce qui implique forcément que l'individu
est un homme donc toutes les femmes
peuvent se rasseoir vous n'êtes pas
suspect est finalement ça confirme en
fait les dires du gardien qui disait
qu'il avait probablement vu un homme
deuxième information nous pouvons
prédire la couleur de peau
et lorsqu'on fait une analyse génétique
on voit que certains individus à des
marqueurs qui sont retrouvés chez les
personnes de type européen donc à ce
moment là on peut prédire une peau de
type clair donc toutes les personnes qui
ont des peaux mates ou foncez vous
n'êtes pas suspecte vous pouvez vous
rasseoir
deuxième élément la couleur des yeux
alors cet individu à des marqueurs très
particulier des marqueurs tendance
marron et des marqueurs tendance bleu et
en génétique le marron et bleu ça fait
une couleur intermédiaire qu'on appelle
le vert donc toutes les personnes qui
n'ont pas les yeux verts peuvent se
rasseoir ça ça marche bien
vous avez des doutes peut-être c'est pas
facile de savoir si on a les yeux verts
on continue passons à la couleur des
cheveux
l'individu à des marqueurs qui sont
retrouvés chez les finlandais chez les
norvégiens donc une coloration plutôt
blonde avec un petit peu de fond c'est
donc toutes les personnes qui sont soit
rousse avec les cheveux noir les cheveux
châtains foncés vous pouvez vous
rasseoir vous êtes plus concernés il ya
déjà il ya beaucoup beaucoup moins de
monde
passons les typologies des cheveux on
est sur une typologie boucler très
bouclés même donc toutes les personnes
avec des shows lice vous pouvez vous
rasseoir également enfin passons aux
prédispositions
premièrement les taches de rousseur
certains individus un risque extrêmement
faible donc il y en a probablement pas
et pas de risque non plus pour tout ce
qui est qu'elle vit si masculine précoce
donc toutes les personnes qui ne
correspondent pas au portrait robot
génétique vous pouvez vous asseoir
effectivement il reste peu de monde donc
ça c'est actuellement ce que le portrait
robot génétique peut vous permettre
d'obtenir comme réponse est pas sans un
petit peu dans le futur on imagine qu'on
ait ôté dit sereine 2018 et dans deux
ans vienne ps va être capable de prédire
l'âge à partir de l'adn et si on le
faisait actuellement on pourrait dire
que l'individu est entre 38 et 42 ans
donc si vous n'êtes pas dans cette
fourchette vous êtes toujours debout
vous pouvez vous rasseoir
autre élément dans quelques années on
pourra prédire la taille et là on est
sur un individu masculin assez grand
emprunt m 81 et 84 ont toutes les
personnes qui ne correspondent pas
essayer vous nous qu'au final vous avez
maintenant la démonstration qu'à partir
d'une salle de 1200 personnes
lorsque vous faites un portrait-robot
génétique finalement votre liste de
suspects potentiels est très très très
réduite et les enquêteurs vont pouvoir
se focaliser spécifiquement sur les
individus qui correspond au portrait
robot génétique
donc il ya beaucoup de lumière mais je
vois quelques individus relever
notamment à l'individu sur la droite il
m'a l'air suspect d'ailleurs et qui
cache sous son fauteuil quelque chose
que monsieur vous pouvez nous montrer ce
que vous avez et voilà la mascotte
poèmes la ramener s'il vous plaît
merci
là vous avez raison évidemment dans une
enquête réelle là l'individu sont laden
serait prélevée on aurait un profil
génétique et on le comparerait au profil
qui était trouvée sur le badge c'était
juste pour être sûr de ne pas se tromper
et bien finalement grâce à vous on a
battu tous les experts et en 12 minutes
on a pu trouver le coupable bravo
alors bien sûr la génétique n'explique
pas tout une coloration artificielle des
cheveux des lentilles de couleur la
chirurgie esthétique
tout ça c'est de l'acquis en fait votre
adn jamais il va pouvoir le prédire pas
plus qu'une cicatrice sur la joue qui va
être un élément qui est très
discriminant pour trouver un agresseur
par exemple ça le problème la génétique
ne pourra pas le faire et donc
finalement le portrait robot génétique
c'est un outil qui est révolutionnaire
parce qu'il va pouvoir donner une
interprétation claires objectives
scientifique qui va être dénué de tout
bien et émotionnel mais il va toujours
falloir un policier pour interpréter ce
résultat et leur place est dans contexte
de l'enquète et chaque fois je parle du
portrait-robot génétique j'ai toujours
une question qui me vient on dit mais tu
penses pas qu'il manque quelque chose
quand même et je dis bah oui ce qui
manque c'est un visage et dans quelques
années ils viennent ps sera capable de
prédire
l'écart entre les yeux la taille entre
le nez la bouche par exemple l'écart
entre la mâchoire tout ça pour faire un
portrait robot faciale de lundi du
calice et son adn donc ça cette méthode
révolutionnaire on a déjà impliqué dans
20 enquêtes criminelles aliens vs
et dans quelques mois nous serons
capable de l'appliquer à des enquêtes ne
sont pas terminées qui sont toujours pas
fermé les fameux col caisse et on espère
qu'avec ça on va pouvoir ouvrir de
nouvelles pistes en fermer d'autres
tout ça dans un seul but la
manifestation de la vérité
alors effectué les frais d'experts